[BEEPS]
[GAME SOUND EFFECTS]
LILIANA YU: Google
Cloud Launcher
offers ready-to-go development
stack solutions and services
to accelerate development.
It provides an easy
and fast way to get up
and running on
Google Cloud Platform
with common databases, operating
systems, and web frameworks.
So you spend less
time installing
and more time developing.
In this Qwiklab, you'll learn
how Google Cloud Launcher lets
you quickly deploy functional
software packages that
run on Google Cloud Platform.
Even if you're
unfamiliar with services
like Compute Engine
or Cloud Storage,
you can easily start up a
familiar software package
without having to
manually configure
the software, virtual
machine instances, storage,
or network settings.
In this lab, Qwiklabs will
provide all the resources
you need to launch a common web
stack with the Cloud Launcher
and verify your deployment.
You'll be deploying
an Nginx stack.
But after taking
this lab, you'll
be able to apply
what you've learned
in your own applications.
On the Cloud
Launcher website, you
can browse what software you can
begin working with right away.
This is the fourth lab in
the GCP Essentials Quest.
A quest is a series of related
labs that form a learning path.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
Next up, learn how to
create a persistent disk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]